civilian volunteers help ukrainian
soldiers prepare for a russian army
advance
there's a growing sense of urgency in
the city of zappariya the ukrainian army
says russian tank columns are less than
40 kilometers away
we didn't invade them they invaded us he
took crimea then he took dom bus now
he's come to our city i have children i
don't want them here giving orders
men move equipment along freshly dug
trenches on the outskirts of town
they overlook checkpoints from positions
hidden in the trees
this is one of a growing number of
checkpoints around the city of zaparisia
now most of the men you see here are
members of the civil defense forces they
are volunteers they say that the russian
army has positioned itself in the next
town down this road
i used to teach maths and physics at my
local school but two days ago the
russian army took control of my town so
i signed up to
fight restaurants including the local
mcdonald's have been donating food
pharmacies have given what medicine they
can spare for the volunteers to treat
the injured
we are here to treat emergencies
stopping bleeding for example we then
take them to hospital armed volunteers
prepare to be taken to positions around
the city
morale is high
close by a group of men and women wait
to sign up
i don't want my family killed i won't
allow them to march on our land they are
the occupiers and they should be
eliminated
if need be i will fight give me a weapon
i want to poison him
the young and old help fill bottles with
petrol
molotov cocktails for those who want to
fight but don't have a gun
yeah i have a family i can't do anything
else to help them
we are honest and bright people but the
situation is dark right now
the people prepare to defend their city
against an invader they know is close
john stratford al jazeera zapo regia
eastern ukraine